this is super interesting because I
jerking li said this at first but but as
we know every great jokes got a hint the
truth in it which was is it really dead
if they have no plan to ever pay it back
right and kind of what we've seen is a
just absolute expansion I think we're at
seventy-five percent expansion of the
Fed's balance sheet over the last kind
of three three and a half months and if
they were to put it through this this
latest rumor proposal of another
trillion-dollar kind of infrastructure
package or whatever it is we'd
essentially see a hundred percent growth
in a twelve month period of the Fed's
balance sheet so kind of you know is it
actually dead or how do you think about
that balance sheet and kind of the
deficit that just seems to literally
just in 2020 every time I see an
estimation as to what the final deficit
for the years gonna be it's just getting
bigger and bigger and literally in some
cases has already doubled from where
they thought they were gonna be at the
beginning of the year to now where they
think they're Amanda yeah so first every
time that I hear a new trillion-dollar
stimulus be announced I immediately buy
that coin
that's my new trigger and I see mean we
get to buy Bitcoin every week so no I do
think so
you know realistically and I think I
think you keyed in on something really
important because if I had the
opportunity to if I was sitting before
Congress for a member of Congress and I
had chairman Powell
sitting in front of me I would ask him
one question and it is did you or did
you not monetize the debts of the United
States because the answer is clearly yes
and this is something that in my work
going back and reading the transit
transcripts from past Fed meetings from
after the financial crisis in around
2011 I believe it was Richard Fisher who
is the Dallas Fed president he basically
can't again I can't quote verbatim but
he made a comment that was long lines of
we need to take the key lock the door
and throw it away on the idea that we
will ever again monetize the debt of our
federal government and there were a lot
of responses that
basically said well we're not monetizing
the debt this is just temporary of
course then Bernanke has gotten on 60
minutes and said and we can remove the
accommodation you know when we need to
and I think there's two problems with it
the first fact is that it's just not
true its fault they maybe believe it to
be true but if they believe it to be
true then they don't understand the
consequences of their actions and and
what I mean by that is if I if I have my
very simplistic wheel it's there's too
much debt not enough dollars through QE
the Fed adds more dollars that creates
more debt and then you get into a world
where you have too much debt again and
that's why each time you know we look at
one of these crises the set is going to
have to put more dollars in to sustain
the credit system because the credit
system is now larger as a function of QE
it's a vicious cycle and so I think the
short answer is yes we are monetizing
debt the longer-term question or
consequence is how long can that
continue because you have a bunch of
children who are monetary modern
monetary theorists that have begun to
think that you know something that
doesn't make any fundamental economic
sense king can go on forever and rather
than spend the time to actually
understand a fundamental economics first
principle to say okay if money doesn't
grow on trees and and that you can't
just print money then just because I
create more degrees of separation and
put it as a Federal Reserve level that
it suddenly makes sense or if it doesn't
if that doesn't make sense on an
individual level an individual balance
xi level on a company's balance sheet
level then oh it makes them at a federal
level because the Fed has this magic
power and you say is it really a magic
power or is there something else that
I'm missing that is causing this system
to continue to be stood up in the
interim but maybe just maybe there's
something very naturally that causes
that to break and so you know when I
when I think about debt monetization the
answer is yes for monetizing debt I
define that as you know as after the
the end of qe3 the Fed's balance she was
four point five trillion and I wrote
about this in Ender's Game which says
then again could have could have been
Kovac could have been the next crisis
inducing financial class but that future
QE wasn't inevitable 'ti because of
because of the degree of system leverage
and so when the Fed began to unwind the
balance sheet in 2017 in the fall 2017
they basically slowly took out seven
hundred billion so they had added three
point six trillion through the process
of QE one two and three and the
definition of if it were truly just
temporary would have been that they had
taken out all of the three point six
trillion they they didn't even get
halfway through QE 3 before the repo
market broke in September and then even
before Cova they added 500 billion so
they basically put back in approximately
75% to 80% of what they had taken out
and now that we're elevated well above
four and a half trillion which is where
the balance sheet stood after QE 3 it is
yes they monetize the debt they can
never they can never get their balance
sheet below four and a half trillion
again because those dollars are all
needed to support an even more levered
financial and so if if I describe
putting dollars in in one sense of
deleveraging the system basically you've
got debt as the the numerator and
dollars as the denominator if you put
more dollars in the denominator your
deleveraging
but if you're taking those dollars back
out and essentially you know reversing
the fact that you've monetized debt then
you have the exact same amount of debt
in the world and you have fewer dollars
to service them so you're actually real
evering the economy as a function of
that operation and eventually it breaks
and you have to put them back in so I
think that there's a reality that while
that is true the amount of debt in the
system and the degree of leverage
actually keeps the system if it's a
precarious balance but it actually keeps
the system together and causes it to
break at the same time what I mean by
that
the
that it's actually the high degrees of
levers that create demand for dollars so
that you can put three point six
trillion dollars in after QE and still
have a world where the dollar generally
holds its purchasing power because so
many people are short them and in many
respects the same dynamic exists today
they're setting you before the you know
March came around with a seventy five
trillion of debt two trillion a dollar
so if you put three trillion dollars in
the system from March to today you're
still at a position where each dollar is
owed 15 times and people are constantly
having to demand dollars and that's
keeping debt that's allowing the dollar
despite the fact that a massive amount
of dollars are being created that is
what causes the dollar to hold its value
because so many people are short of them
and so many people need them now
effectively and ultimately over time you
will get into a situation where that the
amount of dollars that they have to
continue to supply into the system
becomes less and less scarce relative to
the amounts of debt and all while people
are opting out and going to Bitcoin and
as people are opting over to Bitcoin the
marginal demand for dollars becomes
weakened or lesser and lesser over time
and once a critical mass of people are
once the density gets high enough and in
the Bitcoin where all the people holding
Bitcoin and you don't have as many
people constantly demanding dollars
that's when this cycle of QE ultimately
breaks down where they can't continue to
do it because the dollar while they're
doing it doesn't maintain its value